it's time for truth news the good news
cream in your sandwich cookie of news
with me at the desk that cold glass of
milk to my cookie it's rossy ross matt
oh
hi everybody
refreshing that's so funny that's what i
was going to say about this whole glass
of milk is so refreshing as are you
ready oh
thank you
and i'm full fat
you're looking pretty two percent i mean
zero non-fat oh i'm shooting for skim
thank you so much well
you're pulling it off
it's the first day of the most delicious
week there is ross guess what i'm
kicking off
[Applause]
with a toast to our favorite cookies of
all time now ross and i are going to
surprise each other with our favorite
cookies ross what's yours okay i thought
about this long and hard
there are so many cookies to choose from
but
the best cookie of all time in my book
is
the snickerdoodle an underrated cookie
with a little cinnamon sugar on top it's
not too sweet it's not too hot i know
it's kind of everything you want right
underrated cookie
because you know i'm not crazy about
sweets
i'd rather eat a pickle than a cake
you're like a pregnant woman
yeah thank you the cookies i chose today
it has the circus cookies
okay
probably been 10 years since i've had
one of these and they just don't let
down from 10 years too long um okay well
we're kicking off the headlines with the
tale of two unlikely cookie buds
uh-huh
yeah i didn't see these two together
this one i did not see coming either
think about the two people you can
imagine who'd be least likely to be
baking cookies together it's john
travolta and tommy lee yeah
huh the new york post reports apparently
they love trading baking recipes okay
tommy lee posted a video on tick tock
showing his pal john texting him one
wednesday night asking for his killer
peanut butter chocolate chip recipe
and later john shared a pic of his
cookies in the oven calling himself a
regular johnny crocker
and we're in luck because guess what
we've got some of tommy lee's special
recipes right here oh my gosh we have
the this is the the actual peanut butter
cookie recipe and he does it with
chocolate chips in it i heard john
travolta also drinks it with lemonade
i feel like this is wrong on many levels
but i'm going to try it
or there's a little salt okay if you
want the bowl oh tommy lee
[Applause]
drew you cannot tell me that's not a
great peanut butter cookie no
it is
i'm not i think
i'm now i need to like understand the
lemonade
because
it took me a while to get
[Applause]
to the peanut butter but apparently john
travolta likes a lemonade filter with
his peanut butter cookie
i can't second the lemonade sorry johnny
but i
but tommy
that's quite a cookie it's it's the best
i really am enjoying lemonade i never
drink it and it's really it's refreshing
you know what
what i appreciate about a peanut butter
cookie is when they make it with like
the crunchy peanut butter and there's
little bits of peanuts in there and then
they do the thing on the top with the
fork the crisscross oh yeah that's how
you know oh i love that
um okay next up if you're like me and
you never got on board with air pods
who cup of hands uh who likes air pods
yeah everybody everybody loves the ear
pods
so i look at air buds pods whatever the
heck they are and i just think
if you run out of batteries you're no
good to me
that's what you think i do
and so i like the wires because i know
at any point all i have to do is plug it
in and it's always going to be there for
me i'm not willing to play russian
roulette with my earbuds pods whatever
they are
see now i could not disagree with you
more what are you a pilgrim with your
wires
hello
the airport the airpods are the best
invention ever do you know how much i
get done when i'm on the phone i am
doing dishes i'm making the bed i'm
swiffering you don't know what i'm doing
when you're on the phone with me i get a
lot done and it's because of these
airpods i walk around the city and i
have my own soundtrack but i'm shopping
i i could not live without my airpods
well the wall street journal report that
people are ditching the airpods for some
old school wired headphones ooh
apparently i'm not alone rossi okay the
latest cool and casual fashion statement
here's lily rose depp zoe kravitz and
bella hadid with old school headphones
and you know those that girls know a
thing or two
um yeah i mean listen i feel a little
um less alone
um and everyone use what they're into i
guess that's the moral of this okay
okay well then i'm gonna scratch it off
the christmas list for drew okay
i'll be all fashioned about before we go
we've got a fun new game that esther
perel the incredible relationship and
sexuality expert has created she's known
for asking therapy clients questions uh
that are just fascinating and now gq
reports the where should we begin cards
have been turned into a game you can now
play with your partner with friends or
at a dinner party to spark conversations
i actually use these recently i got
these as a gift uh wellington my fiance
his mentor gave them to him and we
thought oh fun and in the car ride home
we started doing them wow the
conversation that came out of these
conversation starters really things
you've never thought to ask somebody
leads to a whole world with even someone
you think you know so well and i have
some cards right here can i ask you
something yes please okay so here's a
question
a text message i regret sending is
[Music]
mine's like oh damn it why is my
television broken for the seventh time
this week why i don't know
and those are your texts yes like why
god why but it's like not to god it's
just someone i work with like now then
i'm like good news i got home and the tv
is on but there's no sound
oh my gosh you know what maybe the cable
will work but the apple tv doesn't work
or maybe the apple tv will work but the
cable doesn't work and if it works it
might not have sound it it usually it
goes like straight to like press the
source button oh yeah we're going to
punch that source button it's the source
button there is no source button it's a
myth
well we
all i want to do is get my tv on we
found the source of drew's anger and we
found that source button i guess those
are the texts i'm a little bit asked
about sunday
do you have one for me okay i do hold on
let's see if i could see into the future
i would want to know
um
i would want to know like what the
iphone 30 feature is you know what i
mean like in 20 years what is it gonna
do
really i do i think about that i do yeah
because yeah it would bug me that's the
thing i think about like i don't want to
like pass away because i'd be so bummed
that i wouldn't get like the next cool
thing the next night oh man i couldn't
have waited just one month yours is very
sweet and practical totally we'll be
right back
[Music]